will the u.s. go to war with Iran will
Joe Biden's campaign survive the weekend
will Roy Moore visit the food court I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well the news cycle is getting very
serious out there we begin today with
the obvious news that the president
considered a strike on Iranian resources
it is unclear at this point where in
Iran we were planning to strike but the
president apparently pulled back at the
very last minute so there were a couple
of conflicting reports last tonight one
from the New York Times one from The
Associated Press about exactly what
happened it was late yesterday and the
president was basically deciding whether
or not to strike Iranian targets the
planes were in the air they were all
ready to go and then they were pulled
back at the very last minute according
to the New York Times president Trump
approved military strikes against Iran
in retaliation for downing an American
surveillance drone but then pulled back
from launching them on Thursday night
after a day of escalating tensions as
late as 7:00 p.m. military and
diplomatic officials were expecting a
strike after intense discussions in
debate at the White House among the
president's top national security
officials and congressional leaders
according to multiple senior
administration officials involved in or
briefed on the deliberations officials
said that the president had initially
approved attacks on a handful of Iranian
targets like radar and missile batteries
the operation was underway in his early
stages when it was called off according
to a senior administration official
planes were already in the air the ships
were in position no missiles had been
fired when word came to stand down
according to the official as all the New
York Times reporting the abrupt reversal
put a halt to what would have been the
president's third military action
against targets in the Middle East
President Trump had twice struck at
targets in Syria in 2017 and 2018
it was not clear according to the New
York Times whether mr. Trump simply
changed his mind on the strikes or
whether the administration altered
course because of logistics or strategy
it was also not clear whether the
attacks might still go forward asked
about the plans for a strike in the
decision to hold back the White House
declined to comment as it Pentagon
officials no government officials asked
the New York Times to withhold the
article and that was the report that was
coming forth from the New York Times and
they talked about a split among
president Trump's advisors senior
administration officials said that
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo John
Bolton the national security advisor in
June Haspel the CIA director
had favored a military response but top
Pentagon officials cautioned that such
an action could result in a spiraling
escalation with risks for American
forces in the region that's the part of
the story that conflicts with The
Associated Press story so The Associated
Press story suggested that the President
of the United States had been advised by
the Pentagon in fact to go ahead they
said that the strikes were recommended
by the Pentagon so apparently the story
isn't even straight within the media as
to who was recommending what the real
question here was whether it was going
to escalate if in fact the United States
took some sort of retaliatory action
obviously President Trump thought that
the answer was maybe so this morning the
president started tweeting out his
foreign policy which again not my
recommendation because in the last 24
hours we have seen the president tweeted
out that Iran made a very big mistake
and then within 24 hours he's tweeting
out why in fact Iran might have just
made a mistake it wasn't actually on
purpose and then he was suggesting that
Iran couldn't be hit because it would
been too provocative or - too
disproportionate here's what the
president tweeted out well guess what
the president tweeted out clarifying his
position in just one second first there
is a widely held belief the
procrastination is a bad thing but life
isn't quite so black and white sometimes
procrastination can work in your favor
hey it may work in our favor
with regard to Romney we would
procrastinate and hit him later but if
you need life insurance and you've been
putting it off congratulations you've
managed to procrastinate long enough for
technology to make it easy policy genius
is the easy way to shop for insurance
online in just two minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
to find your best price once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so if you need life
insurance but you've been busy doing
literally anything else
check out policy genius it's the easy
way to compare all those top insurers
and find the best value for you policy
genius com nobody really wants to shop
for life insurance it means you have to
think about death and the possibility of
plot saying and what happens after but
if you just go take care of it right now
policy genius com can make it super easy
for you go check them out right now be
an adult make sure your family is taken
care of go check out policy genius.com
right now that's policy genius common
okay so the president clarifies his
policy today via twit
again not a huge fan of clarifying
foreign policy via tweet I don't think
that it's a good idea but this is the
president that we have so the president
says President Obama made a desperate
and terrible deal with Iran gave them
one hundred and fifty billion dollars
plus one point eight billion dollars in
cash true Iran was in big trouble and he
bailed them out gave them a free path to
nuclear weapons and soon instead of
saying thank you Iran yell death to
America I terminate a deal which was not
even ratified by Congress and imposed
strong sanctions they are a much
weakened nation today then at the
beginning of my presidency when they
were causing major problems throughout
the Middle East now they are bust okay
so all of this is true and all this is
correct the president was absolutely
correct to pull out of the Iran deal
which was in fact a deal that was
garbage the entire Iran deal was built
to allow Iran to strengthen its regional
ambitions well pledging to hold off on
nuclear weapons just long enough for
them to strengthen their hand and then
as soon as the deal expired in a 10-year
period they flipped the switch and
they've got nuclear weapons and now they
are a regional power with nuclear
weapons the deal was always a crap deal
the Obama administration basically was
paying off the Iranians not to develop
nuclear weapons but to fund terrorism
just so long as Obama was in office and
maybe a little bit beyond if another
Democrat had been elected and then the
president addressed via Twitter what
exactly happened last night he says on
Monday they meaning the Iranians shot
down an unmanned drone flying in
international waters we are cocked and
loaded to retaliate last night on three
different sites when I asked how many
will die 150 people sir was the answer
from in general 10 minutes before the
strike I stopped it not proportionate to
shooting down an unmanned drone he said
I'm in no hurry our military's rebuilt
new and ready to go by far the best in
the world sanctions are biting and more
added last night Iran can never have
nuclear weapons not against the United
States and not against the world okay so
it is that sort of middle tweet there
with which I have some issues and the
one where he actually spells out his
strategy so there are a few problems
with this one he suggests that they were
basically ready to go the planes were in
the air they were on their way and
that's when he asked how many people
will die now the president of the United
States should probably be asking that
question before we load up the Jets and
get out there in the air right that
should be kind of the first
question you ask is what exactly is this
strike and it looked like one of the
consequences of this strike but be that
as it may the president calls it back no
it's his rationale that I have a problem
with and when he says 150 people were
going to die and that was not
proportionate I don't know where this
idiotic notion came from that if you
attack the United States we are supposed
to be proportionate in our response in
fact I think that's a terrible idea
the reason I think that's a terrible
idea is because the United States
actually tried something that was
basically called proportionate response
it was actually called the escalated
graduated escalation during the Vietnam
War there's a strategy put in place by
then Secretary of Defense Robert
McNamara and the strategy which is
elucidated by former Trump national
security adviser HR McMaster in his book
dereliction of duty the book is is all
about how Robert McNamara and the LBJ
administration blew the Vietnam War by
engaging in this graduated escalation
the idea was that we would gradually
turn up the heat
on the Vietnamese and the North
Vietnamese the Vietcong until they
realized that we were going that we were
very serious about this and then they
would back down but that's not really
how military conflict works the reason
that people don't want to get involved
with you in military conflict is because
of they're afraid you will devastate
them not that you will gradually turn up
the heat but that you will devastate
them effectively speaking foreign policy
is much more like a high school
playground than like a debate Society
and a high school junior high playground
there was always the one kid that you
didn't want to fight because he was kind
of crazy
and you never knew what who's gonna do
and there's always that one guy on the
playground who you sort of suspected he
might have a knife in his backpack and
if things went dramatically wrong things
would get really bad for you really
quickly well that's sort of president
Trump's appeal right he said this before
he likes to be unpredictable he likes to
be the guy who is intimidating because
you don't know what he is going to do
the fact is that if Iran knows that they
can trade basically an unmanned US drone
for nothing right the United States is
not going to retaliate in any way do you
think they're gonna stop pushing they
like this they're the ones initiating
this conflict so here's what I ron is
after here around us after a couple of
things one they want to force up the
price of oil so they need chaos in the
region because the sanctions are working
because they have no money they are
deliberately trying to force up the
of oil by creating chaos in the region
they've basically become North Korea
except they are worried about the oil
markets and that brings us to the second
rationale the second rationale is that
they are hoping that the sanctions will
be dismantled if they act militaristic
enough they are hoping that they can
sort of score the same deal that the Kim
regime in North Korea has scored
routinely
with the West which is we act like nut
jobs we launch nuclear tests every so
often we fire a few missiles over the
Sea of Japan and then you sign us a
check and hope that we stop that's what
the Iranians were doing with the Obama
administration it's why they signed the
nuclear deal give us cash and we'll stop
this for the moment and then every so
often we'll act crazy again and then you
give us more cash and then eventually
we'll have enough cash that we can do
exactly what we want to do that's the
goal that is being pursued by the
Iranians and in order to achieve that
goal they also have to make the case to
the Europeans that the Europeans should
basically force the Trump administration
to back down so what they're going to
continue to do now is push and the the
the Stalin line was that you push until
you hit steel and and that's effectively
what the Iranians are doing right now
they're pushing they're pushing they're
pushing because they know that the left
in the United States the press the media
are interested in boxing president Trump
in that they've created this false
narrative where President Trump is the
truly erratic force here the president
Trump is the one who is driving the
conflict the president Trump if only he
were a little bit kinder to the Iranians
none of this would be happening
everything would be going back to the
wonderful way that it was just before
that evil President Trump took office
the Iranians know exactly what the
Europeans think of President Trump they
know what the press thinks of President
Trump and they are playing that to the
hilt that's what this is all of which
suggests that the president is going to
have to take action here sooner or later
truly now the Iranians may be careful
they may be careful enough that they
never shoot down an American man man
aircraft that they don't actually kill
an American that they just sort of keep
this at a low level of boiling conflict
hoping that the Trump administration
will back down but that is not a good
thing either because sooner or later
they will do something that damages us
enough where we do have to retaliate if
you want to stop this thing in his
tracks you do have to show the Iranians
that if thing
get real the ayatollahs are not only not
going to be in charge of a run anymore
they are not going to be breathing
anymore because there's one thing that
the Iranians want that want a lot less
than the United States does and that's a
war it's very funny in the United States
because none of us want to go to war on
I don't want to go to war with Iran you
don't want to go to war with Ron nobody
wants war on
nobody wants hundreds of thousands of
troops invading Iran nobody wants
American lives lost nobody wants any of
those things you know who wants war with
the United States less than the United
States wants war with Iran the Iranian
regime because if it goes to all-out war
if it goes to all-out war that regime
does not stand a chance and we should
note here that there a bunch of options
still on the table for president Trump
but what is being pursued right now
looks a lot like a Clintonian foreign
policy and that is not a good idea I'll
explain in just one second first
I like having straight teeth but did you
know that as you get older your teeth
actually continue to move you think that
you take off the braces in that your
teeth are all set not really that's not
the case your teeth are gonna continue
to move around in your mouth unless you
use kanzen which is the clear
alternative to braces I'm all-in it's
pretty fantastic here's how it works an
orthodontist license in your state
creates a treatment plan for you and
then provides you with a 3d preview of
the final results and then finally they
help bring you these these clear great
basically braces and that keep your
teeth in place if they stop moving
around
ken's it only uses experienced
orthodontist other companies use dental
professionals candid is going to create
custom clear aligners that will be sent
directly to me and my wife that means
that we are not going to have to even go
in to the orthodontist office canton
cost 65% less than braces you can save
thousands of dollars and have straighter
brighter teeth in an average of just six
months i'm really excited to get my
clear aligners from canada i make my
teeth look I mean listen I'm a handsome
man it'll make my teeth look even better
you're one step away from getting
straighter brighter teeth
learn more at cannes at koat.com slash
shapiro use code Shapiro at checkout to
get seventy five dollars off that scans
at koat.com slash up hero code Shapiro
for seventy five bucks off make your
teeth look better and by the way make
your teeth healthier also go check out
cans at koat.com slash Shapiro great for
everybody particularly as he gage go
check them out right now
Canton cocom slash Pierrot coach Shapiro
seventy-five bucks off okay so a couple
of things that we ought to put to bed
right away us striking Iran and knocking
out their Navy for example does not mean
full-scale war with Iran it doesn't
because as I say if the Iranians
retaliated to the point where a
full-scale war were necessary the
ayatollahs are dead
they're atomized they are not living
anymore the United States does have
overwhelming military force with the
most powerful force in the history of
the world the one thing that the
Iranians don't want at the end of all
they say like detention but what they
don't want is the release of tension in
the form of the United States bombing
the living crap out of them
that is not something they actually want
number two if the United States takes
retaliatory action that does not mean
full-scale war I'm very sick of this
false binary that's being driven by the
media that suggests that if the United
States were to retaliate against the
attack on American assets that this
means that war like full-scale a rock
style war is exactly what's going to
happen here in a second I'm gonna read
you a list of the kinetic military
actions that we have taken just since
2010 how many of these devolved into
full-scale war the answer zero-zero the
only one maybe one maybe Libya that's it
okay so here's a bit of a timeline since
2010 of military actions in which the
United States has been involved and
virtually none of these involved a
full-scale war hang in it aside from
2011 when we intervened militarily in
Libya which by the way I opposed aside
from that military intervention every
intervention that I'm about to read to
you does not involve a full-scale war
hey number in 2011 we had drone strikes
on all Shabab militants in Somalia that
was the sixth nation in which we had
carried out those drone strikes
including Afghanistan Pakistan Iraq
Yemen and Libya we sent combat troops as
advisors to Uganda in 2011 we deployed
troops to Jordan to help contain the
Syrian civil war within Syria's borders
in 2012 we sent Patriot missiles to
Turkey to prevent missile strikes from
Syria in 2012 we deployed troops to Chad
in 2012 we deployed troops to Mali in
2012 we conducted a raid in Somalia in
2013 we sent soldiers to Uganda to help
African forces search for Joseph Kony
in 2014 we led in
prevention in Syria that did not evolve
into full-scale war with the Syrian
regime in 2014 and by the way President
Trump has launched two separate military
strikes against Syria in 2017 and 2018
and neither times it had evolved into
full-scale war in 2015 the United States
sent ships to the Strait of Hormuz to
shield vessels after the Iranian seizure
of a commercial vessel Iran fired shots
over the bow and seized the ship and
that's when the Obama administration
chickened out and decided to sign a deal
with the Iranians in 2015 we deployed
300 troops to Cameroon you've never
heard of any of this stuff right the
reason you never heard of any of this
stuff is because not every US military
action devolves into a full-scale war
Eli Lake has a good piece today over a
Bloomberg talking about the various
options that are available to the Trump
administration he suggests that they're
a bunch of things that the United States
could do he says Iran's Revolutionary
Guard Corps and codes force are spread
out throughout the Middle East not only
are senior officials stationed in Syria
Yemen Iraq and Lebanon but they're
around and military outposts in those
countries as well since 2017 the US
intelligence community has prioritized
the mapping of these Iranian forces in
the Middle East options currently under
consideration includes strikes on those
outposts time not to result in
casualties a more serious option under
consideration involves direct lethal
strikes on Iranian commanders stationed
outside of Iran we could also strike
Iranian naval facilities as we did in
1988 1989 in operation praying mantis
and the list of US options is not
limited to traditional warfare we have
cyber operations we could continue to
attack Iranian military computer
networks we need to restore deterrence
obviously and here is where things get
ugly it is obvious that the Democrats
are not interested in restoring any
level of deterrence they're interested
in trying to appease and bribe the
Iranian regime against that in just a
second because we tried that in the
1990s with terrorists it did not work
well first when the founders crafted the
Constitution the first thing they did
was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by the government the second
thing they did was enumerate the right
of the population to protect that speech
and their own persons with force you
know I am a believer in the Second
Amendment I'm a gun owner owning a rifle
isn't
awesome responsibility started in a
garage by marine vet more than two
decades ago
Bravo company manufacturing BCM for
short builds a professional-grade
products which is built to combat
standards this is because BCM believes
the same level of protection should be
provided to every American regardless if
they are a private citizen or a
professional bravo company manufacturing
is not a sporting arms company they
design engineer manufacture life-saving
equipment listen I have a gun not
because I'm great at target shooting or
because I go hunting I don't I have a
gun because if somebody comes to my
house and tries to break in and hurt me
or my family I want to be able to shoot
them the people of BCM know this and
they feel it as their moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the end-user
when it's not just a paper target but
somebody coming to do them harm to learn
more about Bravo company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG comm
where you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news as
Bravo Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing find out even more about BCM
and the amazing people who make their
products it really is a great company at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA go
check them out ok so as I say the left
is militating against any sort of
deterrent action by the United States
because they would prefer to pay off the
worst terror regime on planet Earth
Ben Rhodes was a damned congenital liar
the man behind the ear Anzio who
admitted to the Atlantic that he lied
openly to the American public about the
predicate for the Iran deal he suggested
that the Iran and the Iranian regime was
right on the verge of moderation if only
we'd cut a deal it was all a lie it was
made up he admitted it was all made up
he's out there criticizing the Trump
administration today saying we didn't
need to pull out of a deal that was
working and we don't need to go to war
over a drone let me just point out Ben
Rhodes and the Obama administration went
to war over not a drone over literally
no attacks on American assets in Libya
we went to full-scale war that war ended
with effectively the takeover of the
entire country of Libya by a variety of
terrorist groups and a mass refugee
crisis that ended ups whomping the
southern coasts of Europe so that worked
out great
in other news hasn't the administration
in which he served presided over the
murder of 500,000 people in Syria and
handing over of control of that country
to the Russian government so won't you
sit this one out Ben but not only that
he then tweets out
this is precisely why politics isn't a
game diplomatic agreements should be
honored and temperament intellect and
judgment are what matters in who is
president it should never have come to
this it should never come you know what
might have stopped it from coming to
this if you had taken any sort of
preventative action against Iran
when say your boy was in the White House
when your guy was in the White House
when your man was in the White House
right when this is this is ridiculous
this is just ridiculous okay the fact
that that Ben Rhodes is suggesting that
this is Trump's fault that it's Trump's
problem when it was Obama
that led to the rise of Iran regionally
in the ruin in the area is is pretty
astonishing with that said when it comes
to president Trump's policy when it
comes to president Trump's what
President Trump should do going forward
emulating the Clinton regime or the
Clinton ministration emulating Clinton
who basically sat back and watched al
Qaeda attack the Khobar towers attack
the embassies in the u.s. embassies in
Kenya and Tanzania attacked the USS Cole
and didn't really respond because he was
afraid that the blowback would be too
great on him politically that did not
result in wonderful results for the
United States in fact it resulted in a
belief widespread in the radical Islamic
terror world that the United States was
a weak horse that could be taken and
that was the that was the idea here so
it's you know it pretty pretty
astonishing pretty and again the people
who are sort of defending Trump
vacillating here we'll see where Trump
goes from here but if from continues to
vacillate and do nothing that will have
exactly the same result as if a
Democratic president did the same thing
now listen Trump doesn't want to go to
war this is the thing everybody knows
Trump doesn't go to want to go to war
and this is the part of this that's so
dishonest on the part of the media and
the Democrats they keep suggesting that
Trump desperately wants to take America
into war yesterday president Trump said
openly my administration isn't pushing
me into war he suggested it could have
been something stupid that the Iranians
were doing like Trump desperately does
not want a conflict here
no not at all not at all in fact in many
cases it's the opposite but I will say
look I said I want to get out of these
endless wars I campaigned on that I want
to get out working in Afghanistan for 19
years as you know we've reduced very
substantially in Afghanistan we beat the
Caliphate we took back a hundred percent
of the Caliphate when it was 99 percent
Justin I said we're gonna get out we're
gonna start peeling back and everybody
went crazy because it was 99 so I said
all right so we'll finish it up so we
got a hundred percent but this is
something this is a new wrinkle this is
a new fly in the ointment what happened
shooting down the drone and this country
will not stand for that I can tell you
thank you very much okay so we'll see
where this goes from here naturally
Democrats are creating a false narrative
the Trump is trying to go too soon to
war even though he obviously is not or
that is Trump's fault that it has come
to this it obviously is not at a certain
point the United States will have to
take action here okay because there then
that action can come in a variety of
forms as you I like points out and it
doesn't have to come in the form of a
full-scale war which again nobody wants
nobody wants but all these false
narratives running around that if you
take action against Iran that it's the
end of the world and war is inevitable
and everyone's going to die and all of
this that's not true either some
deterrent force needs to be created here
and obviously what's been happening so
far ain't cutting it okay meanwhile the
Joe Biden campaign is having some
serious trouble according to the
Washington Post tensions ripple through
the Biden campaign as his past working
relationship with the segregationist
senator comes to the forefront according
to the Washington Post Joe Biden was a
freshman senator the youngest member of
the August body when he reached out to
an older colleague for help on one of
his early legislative proposals the
courts were ordering racially segregated
school districts to bus children to
create more integrated classrooms a
practice Biden opposed and wanted to
change Biden wrote on June 30th 1977 I
want you to know that I very much
appreciate your help during this week's
committee meeting in attempting to bring
my anti busing legislation to a vote the
recipients of that entreaty with Senator
James O Eastland at the time a well
known segregationist who had called
blacks an inferior race and once vowed
to prevent blacks and whites from eating
together in Washington the exchange
revealed in a series of letters offers a
new glimpse into an old relationship
that erupted this week as a major
controversy for Biden's presidential
campaign
now as I said before amazing that the
media are just uncovering this now weird
isn't it he was vice president for eight
long years he's been in the Senate for 1
million years Joe Biden he is older than
Methuselah and yet only now are we
digging up these letters from 1977 just
in time for a coordinated assault by
Democrats on his record on race why who
ever would have suspected this sort of
thing and why would Barack Obama have
employed such a vicious racist as vice
president of the United States
Biden's campaign late Thursday issued a
statement saying that the insinuation
that Joe Biden shared the view the same
views on Isla as Eastland on segregation
is a lie nonetheless this is becoming
part of a sort of broader narrative
about Joe Biden that is being pushed not
only by the media but by a lot of his
political rivals he wrote a letter on
March 2nd 1977 to Eastland who was a
racist saying my bill strikes at the
heart of the injustice of court-ordered
busing
it prohibits the federal courts from
disrupting our educational system in the
name of the Constitution where there is
no evidence that the government
officials intended to discriminate he
said I believe there is growing
sentiment in the Congress to curb
unnecessary busing now again this is
them deliberately taking Biden out of
context the fact is that forced busing
was bad policy and led to tremendous
amounts of white flight from the cities
so voluntary sort of segregation and
people who decided to leave particular
areas because they didn't want their
kids to be in in schools with black kids
right there is a push by people that
that instead we would have to have
forced busing and we're going to take
kids from from areas and move them into
other areas black kids into white areas
white kids into black areas and this is
gonna solve all of the problems there's
a difference between mandatory mandatory
integration and the end of legal
desegregation legal least Bellino grazia
has an entire book on this professor
University of Texas law school Biden was
taking the side that you can't force
kids to go to a school that they don't
want to go to and that it's in fact
counterproductive forced busing by the
way was a giant failure as a policy it
did not in fact stop white flight it did
not it did not solve the problems of
school integration it didn't do any of
those things so if you oppose that that
didn't necessarily
from a racist place for some racists
maybe it did but also it may have come
from the idea that the government
doesn't have a role to play here and
also the government isn't effective here
but people are trying to suggest that
it's really because Biden is racist and
we're seeing all sorts of this narrative
pushed out today in 1975 Joe Biden did
an interview in which he said this I
think I've made it possible for liberals
to come out of the closet if it isn't
yet a respectable liberal position it is
no longer a racist one this is his his
pushing against forced busing he says I
think the Democratic Party could stand a
liberal George Wallace someone who's not
afraid to stand up and offend people
someone who wouldn't pander but would
say what the American people know in
their gut is right now the invocation of
George Wallace is being trotted out as
evidence that Joe Biden is racist and
George Wallace was a vicious racist
George Wallace was a segregationist he
believed black people were inferior he
ran for president on that platform he
won some southern states so invoking
George Wallace in 1975 is a pretty ugly
move by Joe Biden at the same time does
that mean that Joe Biden was a closeted
segregationist is that the contention
and does his record since 1975 mean
anything on this sort of stuff is it
possible that Joe Biden is just an idiot
and he says idiotic things on a regular
basis and that seems a lot more
plausible but the media are coming for
old Joe and it's gonna continue in 1981
here's the comments he made again
invoking George Wallace he said
sometimes even George Wallace is right
about some things one of the things that
is happening in this country is that the
American people have given up because
we're not very innovative
let me move off busing to make my points
and then I will end my part of it let us
take the death penalty everybody wants
the death penalty now we are going to
hang everybody do you know why they want
the death penalty because stupid
sociologists and guys like people who
sit up here in my job for years kept
telling them we know how to rehabilitate
they do not have the slightest idea how
to rehabilitate our entire criminal
justice system is premise Don the point
that you sentence someone based upon the
amount of time it will take to
rehabilitate them he says so the
American people because they are
basically good like most people in my
opinion are went along and said we'll
buy that and they bought it for 20 years
and it does not work again this is Joe
Biden circa 1981 and I get killed by my
liberal constituency for saying and I
say hey let's forget about
rehabilitation we do not know how to do
it say it boom tell them because if you
don't you know what is going to happen
eventually people are going to get
frustrated by the way liberal
sociologists and politicians who say we
must rehabilitate our fellow man we must
help them and then they see Richard
Speck come up for parole even though he
did not get it they say my god why
should that be so guess what now they
have only one or two things to choose
between they choose between Strom
Thurmond's you have hanging them or
continue business as usual so this sort
of language is being trotted out as
evidence that Joe Biden is a racist
again invoking George Wallace which is a
bizarre decision but Joe Biden it seems
typically invokes people he thinks are
bad like George Wallace and
segregationist as sort of outliers in
his examples he's been doing it for
thirty years is that evidence that he's
a vicious brutal racist I have a tough
time thinking that that is the case
circa 1992 by the way Joe Biden was
saying that his crime bill would hang
people this is another thing that's
being trotted out to prove that Joe
Biden is actually a vicious racist
because his crime bill was supposedly
targeted at black folks as opposed to a
criminals worth noting then this 1990
new clip 92 clip this is before hair
plugs apparently here is Joe Biden
talking about the crime bill let me tell
you what is in the bill and I'll let you
all decide whether or not this is week
let me get down here a compendium of the
things that are in the bill one the
death penalty it provides 53 death
penalty offenses week as can be you know
we do everything but hang people for
jaywalking in this bill
that's weak stuff so Joe Biden being
raked over the close and you're gonna
see that the entire Democratic Party has
decided to jump into this we'll get to
that in just one second first will you
fight for your freedom so I talk all the
time on the show about growing attacks
on your religious freedom and free
speech well now is the time to tell
people like dr. dub assures he's an
Orthodox Jewish psychotherapist New York
has enacted a law that censor speech
between therapists and clients by
prohibiting treatment of clients who
struggle with same-sex attraction or
gender dysphoria dr. Schwartz could be
punished with fines of up to $10,000 per
fence and somebody comes to dr. Schwartz
I'm suffering with gender dysphoria and
he tries to work through it with them
instead of just bolstering their views
and their delusions and now the state of
New York wants to crack down on him well
this is why the Alliance defending
freedom exists a DF provides free legal
services to dr. Schwartz and others
whose freedoms are under assault but a
DF can't provide these resources without
your help
a DF relies on donations to fight for
your freedom if this attack can happen
to somebody like dr. Schwartz it could
happen to you will you fight for dr.
Schwartz and protect your freedom please
give generously all donations are in
fact tax-deductible and if you donate 75
bucks in above you'll receive an
exclusive free speech shirt go to ADF
Legal org /ban to donate right now
that's a BF legal org slash pen go check
them out a DF legal org slash Ben okay
we're gonna get to more of the Democrats
piling on Joe Biden in just one moment
but first it's that glorious time of the
week when I give a shout out to a daily
wire subscriber today it's Instagram or
David or aka Gondor who not only has a
strong sense of good political content
he also appears to have a strong back in
the picture
David is holding his magnificent leftist
ears tumbler into frame in front of what
looks to be a picture of him as the
bottom of a human pyramid impressive he
writes listening to ben shapiro enjoying
some cold ones hash tag left his tears
tumblr hashtag I came for Ben but stayed
for clayvin well they can't all be
winners if you want a chance of being
featured on the show become a daily wire
annual subscriber if you're not already
one post a photo of your tumblr NIT in
Twitter or Instagram you can even be in
the photo if you'd like to become a
subscriber head on over to daily where
DICOM click on that subscribe button at
the top of the page also when you
subscribe to get early access to buying
tickets for our one night only backstage
live show today at 10 a.m. tickets will
officially go on sale it's the the show
is August 21st at the terrorist theater
in Long Beach California I will be there
daily where god-king jeremy boring and
drew Clavin the horrible Michael Noel's
they will all be there covering politics
pop culture and we'll be answering your
questions live from the audience it's
worth noting there only 300 VIP tickets
available and includes premium seating
photos meet and greets with each of us a
gift from me I don't even know I have to
go and shop for you and more head on
over to Daley wire.com slash backstage
to get your tickets today come join us
for a fantastic evening and of course go
subscribe at Daley we're calm for the
leftist tears tumblr and all the other
wondrous things that you get as a
subscriber
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative pod
Caston radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so the Democrats in the media are
crafting the scenario of where by Joe
Biden is a secret vicious racist and has
been all the waste back since 1975
because he made political forged
political relationships with
segregationists in order to get things
that he wanted done because he opposed
forced busing which again forced busing
was bad policy you might not like white
flight I'm not a huge fan but that does
not mean that forced busing
was a solution to that in fact it was
not it just lets you more white flight
even further out so that you were
outside the forest busing areas the fact
is that you cannot force people to live
where he want them to live in a free
country you just cannot do that and you
can't force people to go to school where
you want them to go to school in a free
country Joe Biden opposed forced busing
therefore he must be some sort of
vicious racist he invokes it George
Wallace a couple of times which again is
a bad move but fully in in line
with Joe Biden being an idiot who says
things without thinking about them fully
and invokes people who are the ultimate
extreme of American politics in order to
make points this is sort of one of his
strategies like I'd even make a deal
with that guy I don't even make a deal
with George Wallace I mean what we need
is somebody who's going to be honest
like George Wallace but also not a piece
of crap like George wall right that's
the kind of way that Biden talks that
doesn't mean that it's great but it also
doesn't mean that he's a vicious racist
but the Democratic Party has decided to
turn on old Joe aoc leading the way Cory
Booker has been attacking Joe Biden and
suggesting that Joe Biden is racist and
then pretending he is not suggesting
that so then what's the criticism aoc
tweeted out for the record Cory Booker
does not Oh Joe Biden an apology for
pointing out that waxing nostalgic about
working with segregationist is
insensitive he knows better really what
is better to stay quiet about it
well no it's better is to not proclaim
that Joe Biden is actually in league
with segregationists and sympathetic to
segregation and if he's not either of
those things then what exactly is the
critique here truly what is the critique
Donaghy C Coates who is of course a
racial racially polarizing figure I
think that he is as I've said wildly
overrated a muddy thinker somebody who
relies on racial polarization in order
to push a particular left-leaning
political agenda he's out there bashing
Joe Biden he says the Joe Biden should
be presidents either
I don't I don't I mean Joe Biden
shouldn't be President
you know you know obviously I don't
think I'm breaking any news here you
know if he ends up being the nominee
better him that hidden him then Trump
but you know I think that's a really
really low standard okay so he's already
out there opposing he was a Biden he was
a Sanders supporter in the last election
cycle Bernie Sanders by the way got into
it with an MSNBC anchor over Joe Biden's
comments as well the entire Democratic
Party is mobilizing against Joe Biden
right now what will be fascinating to
see is whether Biden actually starts to
drop in the polls now we have seen a
drop in the polls for Biden but the the
rich line of attack for Bernie Sanders
in the debates next week will be on Joe
Biden and some of it will be racial
you'll see comel Harris and Cory Booker
do it too Booker's already setting up
for it
so is Booker in the I'm trying remember
I believe Booker is in the debate with
is he in the same debate as mine oh no
he's in the one with Warren okay so so
Biden gets lucky that means that Kamala
Harris is the one who's going to be
attacking Joe Biden over the race issue
because Cory Booker is stuck in the in
the kids table debate with more but
Sanders will go after it also here
Sanders doing just that on MSNBC I don't
think you have to be touting a personal
relationship with people who were very
brutal segregationist I'm sorry if you
disagree with me that's fine that is
that's my good but haven't you over a
four decade career had to align
yourselves with people who don't share
your views on things that you will
advance your causes yeah absolutely just
what I said absolutely I haven't sung as
every other member of the Congress so
then what's the critique the answer is a
lot of this is truly dishonest and again
it is amazing to me that the same media
that suggested beta O'Rourke was heading
world-beating Kansa d't when he was
running against Ted Cruz then they
flipped I said oh hey look at this guy
he's an empty vessel who eats dirt isn't
that weird he's a furry look that's that
we're just noticing this now what a
weirdo with his weird arm movements and
his faux authenticity
we're just noticing that as soon as Ted
Cruz's off the stage all the sudden we
know same thing with Joe Biden when Joe
Biden is running against Paul Ryan as VP
then it's too old Joe so authentic so
true to himself and then he runs against
a bunch
of other Democrats at the media liked
better and suddenly they're
rediscovering how to do basic
investigative journalism how to search
archives and find old things that Joe
Biden has said and report those things
they're finally looking into stuff like
hunter Biden Joe Biden's son doing
business with countries that Joe Biden
was doing business with as vice
president how Joe Biden's son Hunter was
getting magical contracts from
businesses located in China in the
Ukraine while Joe Biden was trying to do
business with China and the Ukraine as
vice president of the United States you
know when that stuff might have been
more helpful to report on when Joe Biden
was vice president of the United States
because all this was public material at
the time but the media apparently the
blinders only come off when it's
convenient which is pretty obvious okay
time for some male bagging so let's
mailbag it up a little bit John says hi
Ben at what point defending do you think
the US should take military action
against a foreign adversary in this case
Iran given that we attacked the Syrian
Air Force infrastructure in 2017 even
without our own forces being attacked
what should the standard be for military
intervention against Iran in this case I
appreciate your thoughts and have a
great weekend well obviously any
military intervention has to be
calculated against what is the goal the
goal in this case is deterring Iran from
attacking ships in the Straits of Hormuz
and the Gulf of Oman and that is the
goal here so if that's the goal it seems
to me that a military intervention to
stop them from doing so by blowing a
couple of their ships out of the water
would probably be a good idea and in
fact there is ample precedent for this
we did it in the 1980s we sank basically
their entire Navy their rinky-dink Navy
in a day when they knock a US drone out
of the sky in 110 million dollar US
drone out of the sky that is in
international territory then knocking
down a couple of their surface-to-air
missile sites that seems like perfectly
proportional and appropriate response
the point is you do what you do to have
to deter the Iranians I'll tell you what
isn't going to deter the Iranians is
sitting there and doing nothing now
maybe it's possible as I suggested
earlier in the show maybe it is possible
that the president merely threatening on
Twitter like guys we were this close to
me knock and you guys we were this close
so cut it out maybe that does the trick
I have serious doubts that that does the
trick
because again the credibility of the
president has to be established by
willingness to use force and the
president has way
hieronymus his wavered from time to time
on the level of force to be used on
whether he wants to use force or not use
force unpredictability and there has to
be a certain level of predictable
unpredictability but it doesn't really
hold when within 24 hours you're saying
Oh Ron made a very big mistake but maybe
they also didn't make a really big
mistake etc Zechariah says hey Ben love
the show and all you guys do at the
Daily wear quick question about the
executive branch does the president have
the power to eliminate the alphabet soup
offices that exist under the executive
branch ie eliminate the DEA or some
other office and then shift those funds
over to Border Patrol I've often
wondered this after the government odd
after the government audit under Barack
Obama showed that several agencies that
were budgetary sinkholes with nothing to
show for all their funding if so why
does no president use that power thanks
Zack well there was a case called u.s.
vs. Nixon in which Nixon said he didn't
want to spend money allocated to the
executive branch by Congress and was
passed over his veto and the Supreme
Court found that the executive branch
couldn't just stop spending the money
and they couldn't just not do what
Congress wanted them to do but the
executive branch could do presumably is
just not ask Congress for the funding or
veto any funding for a particular
department the executive branch does
have the power to fire people within a
department so you could theoretically
eliminate nearly the entirety of a
department and then you know you still
have the money sitting around there as
far as eliminating entire departments
that are established by congressional
Fiat I don't believe the executive
branch can unilaterally just eliminate
the Department of Education legally
speaking I don't think that that's the
case although frankly I'd want to check
it out and I don't know the full answer
luciana says sir Ben as a huge Stephen
King fan for years but over the last few
years I've been hearing his stance on
politics nowadays when I listen to his
audiobooks I hear King's point of view
instead of the stories and I enjoyed do
you think there's a way to separate the
art from the artist longtime listener
first-time member Luciano so number one
I think that it is very important to
separate the art from the artist when we
can there are a lot of horrible people
who create great art and I think we
should still be able to enjoy the art
created by horrible people the truth is
virtually everybody is flawed to some
extent or another you can always find an
excuse some excuses are great some
excuses are bad as to why you should
engage or not engage with somebody but
art is separate from the artist the
problem for King is the King has
actually infused his books with his
politics that makes it very difficult
so it would be one thing if king were
just writing books that were a political
but very often lately I also have read
many many Stephen King books I think
particularly his premises of his books
are really interesting and then he has
no idea how to finish them this is the
common pattern to Stephen King basically
a Stephen King book starts out with this
really interesting premise and something
interesting happened something odd and
interesting and then it progresses for
300 pages of pulp and then he blows
everything up that has been the ending
to I think his last three books last
four books at the very end everything
just sort of goes on fire and explodes
and that's annoying just from an
artistic point of view but what's even
more annoying is all of this there's I
remember I read under the dome and in
under the dome every villain is a
caricature of some sort of right-wing
hick ridiculous figure who's secretly
who's secretly disgusting and terrible
even though they're a bible-thumper and
King has this very John Lithgow in
Footloose view of what conservatives are
and it's it's very irritating and very
self flattering for King Abraham says if
a country has a trade deficit year after
year doesn't it eventually run out of
money how's the sustainable year after
year if we buy 500 billion dollars and
sell only one hundred billion dollars
doesn't it wind up his debt no that is
not how trade deficits work so a trade
deficit people misunderstand what a
trade deficit is a trade deficit is not
the United States government spends more
than it takes in that's just a deficit a
trade deficit is that the members of the
United States Siddons citizenry spend
more on products from foreign countries
than those countries spend on the United
States but that money doesn't just
disappear so you spend a hundred bucks
on a product from China what happens to
that hundred dollars well the Chinese
can't use it in their own commerce they
don't use dollars for commerce instead
they're going to have to use that money
for investment and so very often they
will use that capital for capital
reinvestment they'll buy American bonds
or they'll buy American companies or
they'll invest in American real estate
balance of trade is is not in my opinion
an important indicator of the economic
health of a country I mean you don't
have a balance of trade with your
supermarket you buy stuff from your
supermarket all the time presumably the
supermarket doesn't buy nearly as much
from you as you buy from the supermarket
does that mean that you have been
damaged by the supermarket you're
running a trade deficit with them the
answer is no right because now you saved
money presumably the reason you shopped
at the supermarket you didn't grow all
the food in your backyard
you wanted to save money so trade
deficit can actually for you make a lot
of sense and for the citizenry it can
make a lot of sense now there's an
argument that is often made that a trade
deficit hollows out particular
industries because basically you're
buying from places that are not American
that is true
there's no question that if you buy from
a place that is not American an American
business didn't get your business but
again those dollars end up reinvested
into the American economy over time
those dollars end up invested into
presumably more lucrative and more
efficient American businesses this is
the concept of comparative advantage
let's see
Dominick's has been which if any
charities you support and want to donate
would rather ask you than do any real
work thank you well that there are many
great charities I support a bunch of
pro-life charities I support a bunch of
Jewish charities obviously as a
religious Jew I support a lot of
religious charities I support like the
Gary Sinise Foundation which is a
pro-military
charity I'm trying to remember where I
get I give a fair bit of charity last
year I'm trying to remember the exact
list of organizations to which I gave it
was somewhere between five and ten
charities that I signed fairly large
checks to I'll get a list of it but yeah
I mean there are a lot of wonderful
charities out there John says hello Ben
I originally subscribed during the Box
ad pocalypse if President Trump wins
re-election and the left goes so far
left that they will hit a brick wall and
then blow open that wall so they can go
even further left do you think that the
moderate Democrats currently keeping
quiet will start to push back against
the radical left and try to take back
the party from crazy people
I really doubt this I really doubt this
because I think that the left has been
driven so fully insane by President
Trump and that they live in such a
delusional world that they believe that
they are not sufficiently committed to
the left and that's why they lost in
2016 and I think the same thing will be
true in 2020 if Joe Biden is the nominee
and they lose they'll say we were to
moderate and if it is somebody who's
more woke and they lose then it will be
well we just need to get out there and
fight harder I think that the Democratic
Party has engaged in a sort of bizarre
myth of its own creation and that myth
is that Barack Obama assured in a new
political world that Barack Obama
changed the status of American politics
forever and then another Democrat could
pick up that mantle and run with it and
basically the proposition was that
before this is a 50/50 country Barack
Obama made it into a fifth
2:48 country or 5347 country and those
specifically because of the outsized
contribution of minorities to Barack
Obama's electoral coalition so they
could safely ignore blue-collar white
folks they could safely ignore the Rust
Belt they could safely ignore all of
these places and focus in only on urban
areas drive out turnout in those urban
areas and win reelection from here to
the end of time there's a lot of talk
about this in the left comment area from
2008 to 2016 how basically a new
demographic shift and the rise of the
Millennial Generation meant that you no
longer have to appeal to the old
constituencies now Democrats are wrong
about this it turns out that Barack
Obama was not a transformational figure
he was a unique figure he's uniquely
talented he had a unique draw
particularly with the black population
voting population of the United States
and because of all of that he was
uniquely capable of drawing outsized
votes for himself but it didn't
translate over to other Democrats and
you could see that it didn't translate
over to other Democrats because he lost
virtually every state house in the
country over the course of his
presidency so Democrats instant but I
think the Democrats are so delusional
that they think that it was basically
such a fluke in 2016 that all they have
to do is keep doubling down on what
brought them Barack Obama and they'll be
fine so I don't think they're gonna
shift back to the center Jacob says why
are so many celebrities leftist well I
think a lot of celebrities are leftist
because to be in the arts and I know a
lot of artists people that a lot of
artists our people who consider
themselves sort of outcasts as sort of
the weirdos in their communities or the
weirdos in their where they grew up the
free thinkers the people who are held
down by the man and then they escaped a
beautiful Hollywood and then they
decided that they were going to become
more tolerant and diverse and leave
behind the foolishness of their parents
because they're artistes and they've the
artiste mentality and also there's
something about art that is inherently
subjective and so I think many artists
rightly believe that there's a fair
amount of luck involved in their success
there are a lot of good actors who are
working on coffee bean right now there
are a lot of terrific script writers who
presumably are managing coffee beans
right now and the only thing that
separates them from the people who are
working in Hollywood is a fair bit of
luck so there's a feeling of sort of
randomization that occurs in the
celebrity world like did I work hard for
this but it's not like those other
people didn't work hard for it it was
just sort of randomized and so there's a
real guilt complex that live
in sort of celebrity halls and a lot of
those celebrities feel the necessity to
pay off the social justice warrior types
to make amends for their own success -
to make amends for not being a starving
artist but for being a quote-unquote
sellout by engaging in extraordinarily
woke politics designed to appeal to the
fringes of American life and to chide
the American people from whom they draw
their money there you see this very
often with artists they start to disdain
the audience that actually pays them and
it's it's an ugly thing and it makes for
worse art by the way see Nicholas says
haben as a self-proclaimed patriotic
Christian conservative who also happens
to be gay I've enjoyed listening to your
recent discussions on same-sex marriage
and its relationship with religion
specifically you mentioned that well you
don't believe the government should be
in the business of marriage you as an
individual would not attend a gay
wedding because you believe the act is a
sin I just wanted to probe this point a
bit more perhaps to understand it better
which would be amenable to attending a
wedding between two atheists being that
completely secular marriage is
presumably also not endorsed by Judaism
well no I don't think that it is a sin
for heterosexual people to be married
outside of a church and I don't think
that that is a sin in the Jewish view
right the the question of same-sex
marriage is the idea that homosexuality
not the orientation but the actual act
of the sin itself or the legitimization
of that sin is the sin the heterosexual
act is not in and of itself in a married
context a sin under Judaism says do you
think this perspective could change you
say a child's or other close relative
were to come out as gay I don't think so
and the reason I don't think so is
because my definition of sin does not
mean that I'm unsympathetic to people
who are gay this is something that I
think folks need to understand about
people who are religious I've tremendous
sympathy for people who are homosexual
or in orientation I friends I have
family who are in fact gay and that does
not mean that I think that the sin
itself is no longer a sin but it also
means that I've tremendous sympathy for
them I just can't participate in the
celebration of something that i
religiously consider to be a sin and by
the way this doesn't just extend to
homosexuality and same-sex marriages I
mean when I was on Dave Reubens show I
talked about this this extends in
Judaism to intermarriage I can't attend
an intermarriage if a non Jew marries a
Jew I can't go to that wedding because
that is a sin according to Jewish law
it says just so you know I'm not of the
mindset that your viewpoints on this
make you or anyone else a bigoted
homophobe monster in fact I think quite
the opposite our shared perspective on
individual liberty and personal freedom
are what make America in 2019 the best
time and place in the history of the
world to be gay looking forward to
hearing a bit more about your views
thanks big fan love the show well I
appreciate it you know one of the things
that I've always found bizarre is why
people care what I think is a sin I
think all sorts of things are sins right
I'm I'm an Orthodox Jew that means that
like everything is sinful a lot of
things and I can recognize that I don't
live up to all my own standards when it
comes to sin because no one does and I
can acknowledge that people sin what I
can't do is suggest that a sin is not a
sin or celebrate what I consider to be a
sin but that's not the same thing as
suggesting that the government should be
involved in enforcing my vision of sin
on the world that I think is a mistake
there's no secular rationale for it so
if you don't like what I think is a sin
I have good good news for you you don't
have to care because I'm not imposing it
on you Blake says hi Ben what in your
opinion is a proportional response to
recent Iranian aggression I'm not in
favor of proportional response as I said
earlier I'm in favor of disproportionate
response sufficient to establish
deterrence Corey says hey Ben just
subscribed in part due to recent big
tech conservative censorship my question
is when do taxes move from legitimate
governmental income to theft
thanks well there's a great book by
Richard Epstein called takings and his
basic theory is that under the fifth
amendment which talks about presumably
eminent domain it said that the
government cannot take private public
sorry private property for public use
without just compensation that is the
that is the language that is used no
private property for public use without
just compensation Richard Epstein
suggests I think quite correctly that
what this means the government can't
take your property and then not
compensate you for that property in some
way so what that means is that if they
take my money for taxes and then they
use it for services from the police that
I can access that is one thing if they
take my money and just hand it to Bob
over there I'm not getting compensated
in any way for that that is an
illegitimate taking I think that is a
good framework for thinking about taxes
Raphael says hello mr. Shapiro Bernie
recently tweeted he supports unions in
the gaming industry since they made over
40 billion last year well he didn't just
we dad he suggested that the gaming
industry grossed over 40 billion last
year and that the 40 billion should
therefore be distributed among the
workers he demonstrated that he
literally does not understand the
difference between gross and
yet so he thinks that because the gaming
industry made 40 billion dollars last
year
that means they profited 40 billion
dollars last year which is idiotic
hey the vast majority of that went to
the people who work for the gaming
industry and I've heard some downsides
this Rafael of union of industries
unionizing can you remind me of those
downsides especially for an industry as
huge as the gaming industry thanks love
the show well the problem with
unionization typically is that it makes
business is less efficient now I'm in
favor of private union so long as
they're not kneecapping people if you
want to get together with all your
friends and then unionize and you're not
trying to kneecap scabs and you're not
trying to use physical force against
anybody enjoy all for it don't see a
problem with it if however what you're
talking about is forced collective
bargaining where I have to negotiate
with you as the employer by law then
you're talking about carta lysing the
industry and basically putting the
workers in control of a business they
did not capitalize in the first place if
I can hire somebody more efficiently
than you I should be able to hire
somebody more efficiently than you also
the reason that so many members of
private industry have decided not to
unionize I mean because the unionization
rate in the United States went from
something like 60% to something like 5%
over the last several decades the reason
that that happened is because people
decided wait a second what unions very
often do is they guarantee a stagnating
business that I work for that becomes
unprofitable and has to fire people also
very often what unions guarantee is
seniority so I may be a better qualified
younger employee and I can't get a raise
because there's somebody else who's
older than I am who's a dunderhead but
the union contract says that person has
to get a raise before I do I'd rather
operate in a freewheeling manner in
which I can go in and ask for an
individual raise anytime I want union
contracts usually forbid that sort of
thing and that's sort of the story with
unions okay time for a quick thing I
like and then a quick thing that I hate
and then we will be out of here so
things that I like today so there's a
really good book edited by Maher
salivate check he's a rabbi at you
should be University and Stuart Halpern
writes the book it is called proclaim
Liberty throughout the land the Hebrew
Bible in the United States a source book
so what's great about this book it's
from Toby Press what it what it is
designed to do is provide the
foundational biblical texts that a lot
of early thinkers ranging from
john winthrop all the way up through
Abraham Lincoln relied upon in the
forming of their philosophy the book
doesn't suggest that America is a quote
unquote biblical country or a Christian
country it does suggest that the
background for a lot of the thought of
the founders was in fact biblical
thinking that that was the backdrop and
that organically speaking the Bible has
a lot to do with the founding of the
United States because it infused
everybody's thinking and so it really
kind of points out how that happened
takes takes foundational documents in
the history of the United States and
connects them with the source text in
the Bible it's a really good resource I
think it's a lot of fun go check it out
proclaim Liberty throughout the land the
Hebrew Bible in the United States a
source book worth worth checking out ok
time for one more thing I like so
Condoleezza Rice was questioned
specifically by an NBC reporter who
wanted her to suggest that President
Trump has radically reduced the quality
of race relations in the United States
and condi rice who lived through
segregation who watched her church
firebomb
she had some words people say it feels
worse now when we're talking about race
or it sure doesn't feel worse than when
I grew up in Jim Crow Alabama
ok so let's drop this notion that we're
worse than race relations today than we
were in the past really that means we've
made no progress really and so I think
the hyperbole about how much worse it is
isn't doing us any good we still have
this country it's never gonna be
colorblind we had the initial original
sin of slavery it's still with us ok so
what she says there is that you should
put all this in perspective which of
course is true and we can look at
history and we can recognize the value
of history and we can also recognize
that in a free country
the way for us to all get along is to
live under equal protection of the laws
which should have been enshrined in the
14th amendment and then applied by the
federal government and was not for over
a century afterward but condi is putting
things in context yeah the media should
should definitely take that under
consideration
time for a quick thing that I hate
so Alexander Ocasio Cortez keeps
doubling down we're now and what day
four of her refusing to acknowledge that
calling detention centers concentration
camps is an idiotic thing she doubled
down on it again yesterday she keeps
digging eventually she's going to
actually reach China she's gonna dig a
hole all the way through the earth she's
gonna hit the molten core and keep going
here's a Aussie once again doubling down
[Music]
it takes a process slow a gradual
process of increasingly dehumanized
stuff okay this is again she's quoting
the experts you name them explain how
many books have you read and constants
concentration camps explain how this is
about the bowler war the media will
continue to defend her because they will
defend anyone but anyone on the Left
anyway
who is useful to them in the moment
until they become not useful like Joe
Biden and they are put out to pasture
like Edward G Robinson in Soylent Green
but AOC will continue to double down
because nobody on the left will ever
call her out on it it's pretty
impressive and if they do call her out
like Chuck Todd then they get relaxed as
well
okay we'll be back here later today with
two additional hours of contents i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily white or
2019 hey guys over on the Matt Walsh
show today the Democrats have decided
suddenly now that Joe Biden is racist
now if that's true why are they just
noticing now after 50 years also I want
to talk about the danger of misleading
and dishonest headlines and which is a
scourge now an epidemic and how we can
guard ourselves against it finally are
we putting teachers in a basically
impossible situation by sending them
legions of poorly parented
out-of-control kids to educate I would
say yes we are
and so we'll talk about that also today
over on the Matt Walsh show